Мене звати Жанна Нємцова. Це спеціальний випуск програми,
присвячений 5-ій річниці Євромайдану.
Сьогодні на відеозв’язку з Києва Мустафа Найєм.
Восени 2014-го він обрався до Верховної Ради
за списком блоку Петра Порошенка.
У 2018-му році Мустафу внесли
до російського санкційного списку.
Мустафо, велике спасибі за інтерв'ю і ласкаво просимо в програму.
Отже 21-го листопада за закликом Мустафи Найєма, тоді ще журналіста,
на площі Незалежності в Києві зібралися активісти -
на знак протесту проти відмови тодішнього президента Віктора Януковича
підписати угоду про асоціацію України та ЄС.
Мустафо, чи очікували ви тоді саме такої реакції
президента Росії Володимира Путіна на події на Майдані?
Насправді… Ну, по-перше, доброго вечора, дякую за запрошення.
Я не можу сказати, що ми думали навіть про цю реакції.
Мені було байдуже, оскільки ми займалися своїми справами в своїй країні.
Тому реакції Володимира Путіна ми не знали, але ми знали,
що існують певні домовленості між ним і керівництвом нашої країни
про те, що процес євроінтеграції буде призупинено або загальмовано.
Тому інтуїтивно ми десь здогадувалися про те,
що, ну скажімо так, ніхто цим задоволений не буде.
Але ви були готові саме до такого розвитку подій, до якого призвели події на Майдані?
Я маю на увазі й анексію Криму, і наступну війну на Донбасі?
Зараз ми розуміємо, що наше покоління, ті люди, які виходили на Майдан
5 років тому - це люди, які б'ють історичний рекорд саме незалежності
і державності України. Бо все те, що відбувалося в подальшому і з Кримом, і з Донбасом,
зараз вже очевидно, що це логічне продовження,
логічна реакція на вибір покоління, вибір країни, вибір людей.
І на те, що країна захотіла мати своє власне майбутнє,
і воно не було не пов'язане з Російською Федерацією і з нашим минулим.
Тому звичайно тоді ніхто не припускав,
але вже зараз очевидно, що це ланцюг однієї й тієї ж історичної парадигми,
в якій Російська Федерація намагається привласнити собі і майбутнє,
і вибір сусідніх країн - зокрема й України.
Тоді ми були змушені боротися за незалежний вибір країни
і незалежний вибір покоління. Тому ні, ми не припускали,
але це було логічним продовженням.
Ось тоді в ході багатоденних і багатотисячних протестів
у результаті снайперського вогню загинули понад сто активістів.
Це відбувалося наприкінці лютого 2014 року.
Когось покарали?
Якщо ви мене запитаєте, чи відновлена справедливість щодо тих людей,
і були поранені, та які потім загинули на війні – звичайно, що ні.
І більш того, існують певні проблеми з тим, щоб цих людей
переслідувати в кримінальному порядку, оскільки середня ланка правоохоронних органів,
тобто люди безпосередньо причетні до політичного переслідування протестувальників на Майдані,
так ось ця середня ланка досі залишається і в прокуратурі,
і в органах досудового розслідування. І зараз я можу сказати тільки,
що завдяки зусиллям всього лише невеликої жменьки людей
у прокуратурі та правоохоронних органах такі процеси в принципі тривають.
Але, на жаль, це не стало пріоритетом ані для колишніх генпрокурорів,
ані для нинішнього генпрокурора, який максимально дискредитує цей процес.
Ми знаємо конкретні підрозділи на той момент
внутрішніх військ і міліції, які брали участь у розстрілах.
Ми знаємо підрозділи, ми знаємо групу осіб...
Частково це люди, які залишилися в країні, а частково – які втекли.
Але встановити конкретно, наприклад, в кримінальному процесі,
яка людина, з якої зброї та якою кулею вбила яку конкретну людину -
досить складно. Тобто навіть якщо встановити підрозділи,
то когось люстрували, хтось продовжує працювати,
і довести цю справу до суду досить важко.
Сукупність усіх цих факторів вказує на те, що
якби була політична воля, то, я думаю, в якийсь момент був шанс.
Але зараз ці події дедалі більше відходять,
і за нинішнього керівництва я не бачу можливості, що це може бути з’ясовано...
Ви саме згадали політичну систему, яка склалася після Майдану.
Ось через п'ять років ми бачимо, що зміни політичного класу не відбулося,
при владі досі ті ж люди.
Президент Порошенко прийшов в українську політику в середині 90-х
і в складі абсолютно іншої партії з іншою політичною платформою.
Більше того, він - один з найбагатших людей України.
У президентських рейтингах нині лідирує Юлія Тимошенко,
вона ветеран української політики. Всі олігархи досі мають вплив.
Можливо, з них тільки пан Коломойський перебуває не в Україні, але його вплив зберігається.
Чому в Україні не з'явився свій Навальний,
ось така справді впливова людина,
чому вплив досі мають люди минулого?
За усієї поваги до Навальному, я думаю, що в Україні багато Навальних.
Справа в тому, що Навальний - одна людина в Росії,
яка розслідує корупцію і показує щось.
Якщо приїдете в Україну, ви такі розслідування
щотижня побачите на центральному телебаченні.
Україна в цьому плані політично, звичайно,
набагато більш просунута держава, ніж Росія,
і тут річниця очевидна. Що стосується, чому не з'явився.
Згадаємо, як це відбувалося.
20-го лютого закінчИлися події на Майдані, коли втік президент
і буквально через кілька днів почалася анексія Криму, війна.
Багато людей, які стояли на Майдані, були змушені поїхати на фронт.
Другий момент: вже до часу виборів президента і парламенту
не було порядку денного тільки Майдану, про який ми говорили на Майдані.
Бо тоді ми говорили не про війну, а про реформи, корупцію,
прозорість влади, виборчий процес.
Ось всю цю програму повністю перекреслив порядок денний війни.
Згадаймо, під якими гаслами президент Порошенко виграв вибори -
він пропонував мир. І, звичайно, у зв'язку з цим говорити про те,
що це був чистий політичний процес, в якому люди здійснили революцію
і ось вони прийшли до влади, але чомусь не наполягли на своїй програмі, -
це було б нечесно і неправильно стосовно країни та її громадян.
Тому що ті люди, які хотіли щось змінити і вийшли на Майдан,
стикнулися з кулями, а не просто з політичним процесом.
І в цьому сенсі, звичайно, наше покоління людей, яким 25-30 років,
були не готові до того, що країну будуть захоплювати,
відкушувати у неї території. Але з іншого боку, якщо ви порівняєте, наприклад,
те, що зараз відбувається, і ситуацію п'ятирічної давнини,
то багато в чому стара еліта копіює нас, а не навпаки.
Якщо раніше молодь хотіла стати крутими політиками,
які їздять на мерседесах і керують усім - судами, правоохоронними органами,
то нині старі політики намагаються робити вигляд, що вони антикорупціонери,
що вони прогресивні, що вони розуміють щось в новому поколінні.
У них навіть гасла - це копія того, що хоче нове покоління.
Мустафо, я хочу ключове сказати, вибачте, що перебиваю.
що вони намагаються робити вигляд,  не є справді чесними політиками.
Ось у чому проблема
Дивіться, однією з вимог Майдану була радикальна боротьба з корупцією.
Я подивилася рейтинги Трансперенсі Інтернешнл
щодо сприйняття корупції за 2017 рік.
Україна - на 130-му місці з 180-ти країн.
При цьому ви говорите ось у вас на центральних телеканалах викривають факти корупції.
Але не варто забувати, що в країні відбулося кілька резонансних,  я вважаю,
я вважаю, політично мотивованих вбивств журналістів і активістів,
які розслідували корупцію.
Це і Павло Шеремет, як ви пам'ятаєте в 2016 році,
російський журналіст, який жив в Україні.
Це Катерина Гандзюк, буквально недавно в листопаді 2018 року.
Трансперенсі наводила й інші приклади.
Тобто боротьба з корупцією - це декларація влади,
а насправді вона розправляється з тими людьми,
які дійсно хочуть боротися з корупцією. І просто залякує цих людей.
Ну дивіться, давайте будемо справедливими, різниця є.
П'ять років тому ви навіть цього не могли побачити на центральному телебаченні.
Я навіть не буду порівнювати з тим, що відбувається в країнах навколо нас
маю на увазі, наприклад, нашого північного сусіда Білорусь.
Але я пам'ятаю, як п'ять років тому за слово "Межигір'я"
тобто резиденція Віктора Януковича, вимикали з ефіру
Я втратив роботу. Я пам'ятаю, що було нереально, неможливо на будь-якому каналі в принципі
побачити розслідування будь-якої корупції.
Це була тема, повністю витіснена в інтернет
Зараз це є – і це плюс.
Тепер що стосується того, що дійсно є і нападки на активістів.
Ми знаємо ті приклади, які ви навели.
І Павло Шеремет був моїм близьким товаришем.
І Катерина Гадзюк, та дівчина, яка загинула, яку вбили, фактично, кілька місяців тому
Це наслідок цієї боротьби
Тобто якщо хтось думав, що боротьба буде легкою і простою, то це, на жаль, не так
Так, це величезне, в лапках "досягнення" нинішньої влади
яка, на жаль, за старими кальками атакує громадянське суспільство
яке намагається щось довести, намагається говорити про корупцію
І в цьому сенсі її інститути залишилися такими ж
І я з вами погоджуся, що, звичайно, це імітація,
звичайно, це спроба копіювати боротьбу з корупцією
як спроба копіювати нові тенденції, прогресивність, а не їхнє реальне існування
Та це дає надію, що ми зможемо це змінити
І більш того, я вам скажу, що завдяки саме цьому громадянському суспільству
багато антикорупційних процесів, які мали місце в країні, вони відбулися
Мустафо, ви підняли досить важливу і болючу тему
Я переглянула останні президентські рейтинги
адже в Україні наступного року відбудуться і президентські, і парламентські вибори
Президентські вибори - 31-го березня
І ось 13 листопада Центр Разумкова говорить взагалі якийсь жах
лідирує Тимошенко - 21 відсоток, за нею Зеленський, а потім Порошенко - 10%.
Тимошенко - найпопулярніший політик в Україні
Тобто у людей повне розчарування новими силами
вони не бачать жодного потенціалу за новими людьми
Я не думаю, що це остаточний електоральний зліпок того, що ми отримаємо 31-го березня
на президентських виборах або в жовтні на парламентських.
Тому, так, звичайно, зараз є такі рейтинги
вони абсолютно логічні, зрозумілі.
І пояснюються не популярністю цих політиків
адже досі 53% людей не знають, за кого вони проголосують
А пояснюється це структурними і матеріальними перевагами старих політиків
які ті мали, бо вибачте, вони починали тоді, коли ми з вами ще до школи ходили
У 97-му році Юлія Володимирівна Тимошенко прийшла у Верховну Раду депутатом
Я сам був тоді в школі, думаю, що ви також ще вчилися в перших класах.
І, звичайно, для мене присутність і Юлії Тимошенко, і Петра Порошенка,
і багатьох людей з цього списку кандидатів
це така політична геронтофілія, минуле, архаїзм
Але знову ж таки підкреслю, це має пояснення
І так само як є очевидний природний процес історичний
який показує що попри всі ці бажання, попри всі ці зв'язки зі старим,
зі старими елітами, з нашим радянським минулим, люди йдуть в іншому напрямку
І я впевнений, що наші погляди і погляди тих, хто виходив перший раз на Майдан
вони все ж мають першорядне значення в суспільстві
Бо, наприклад, багато тих політиків, яких ви зараз назвали, були причетні до попередньої влади
Петро Олексійович Порошенко був міністром економіки при Януковичі
і, більш того, заснував Партію Регіонів.
Юлія Володимирівна Тимошенко 2009-го укладала угоду з Віктором Януковичем
про розподіл влади в країні
Про що ми говоримо?! Тобто ці люди цілком органічно почуваються з тієї елітою
яку ми п'ять років тому вигнали з країни
У мене до вас останнє запитання, і я попрошу коротку відповідь
хоча воно досить непросте
Повертаючись до Майдану, люди вийшли через відмову Януковича
підписати угоду про асоціацію з Євросоюзом
Повністю угоду підписали 2017-го
При цьому ми бачимо, що підписання цієї угоди не стало тригером для економічного зростання
Чи мав рацію Янукович, коли говорив, що ця угода невигідна?
Адже, можливо, він мав на увазі не лише економічну складову
а й уявляв собі дії Росії щодо України?
Відповім коротко. Я просто вам поясню
Вам варто все ж вивчити історію питання і все ж заглибитися в цифри
Коли Віктор Янукович заявив, що угода не дійсна
це сталося після того, як він у Сочі отримав 12 мільярдів гарантій від Володимира Путіна
Вам це відомо.
А до цього протягом трьох років Віктор Янукович особисто - особисто! - ще раз наголошую
переконував і нас, і уряд, що треба підписувати угоду про асоціацію
І підготував безліч законопроектів, зокрема, в економічній сфері
для того, щоб ми підписали цю угоду
Тепер що стосується економічної складової.
Я хочу наголосити на тому, що ми втратили третину нашої валютного прибутку
за рахунок того, що втратили території, на яких були розміщені наші гірничо-збагачувальні комбінати,
де були металообробні заводи
Так ось. Попри це в країні немає відкату
Зараз рівень економічного зростання та рівень економіки вирівнюється до рівня 2013-го року
І це, Жанно, під час війни!
Тобто ми втрачаємо величезні гроші тільки стримуючи російську агресію
І другий момент, якщо ви подивитеся на структуру товарообігу між нами і Європейським Союзом,
між нами та іншими країнами
то, звичайно ж, ви не маєте рації
остільки саме угода про асоціацію дала нам змогу знайти нові ринки
і продавати не застарілу продукцію, як Росія
яка вже не може вийти на зовнішні ринки, окрім як ринок озброєнь
Так ось, ми вже продаємо цю продукцію на європейські ринки
Так, це важко, так, це змушує закривати багато виробництв
які не є конкурентоспроможними
Але це ключ до майбутнього. І, я ще раз підкреслю, ми вже виходимо на рівень 2013 року
попри те, що за рахунок металу і вугілля втратили величезний валютний прибуток
Тому, звичайно ж, з точки зору економіки ця угода була абсолютно обґрунтованою.
Але ще раз наголошу, саме тому що ми не хотіли керуватися тільки шлунком і холодильником
ми і вийшли на вулицю
І я радий, що попри те, що нам доводили, що це неможливо
що ми помремо з голоду і що нас годує Донбас, як ви пам'ятаєте
або що нас годує Російська Федерація і тільки за рахунок її газу ми й живемо
все ж виявилося, що це не так
Попри це, всупереч війні, попри те, що відбувається в країні, ми помалу оживаємо
Я можу багато в чому критикувати наше керівництво
та буду критикувати і за крадіжки, і за корупцію, і за все, що відбувається в цій сфері
Але найважливіше - ми вперше отримали ту державу
те керівництво країни, яке не продає наші інтереси Російській Федерації
Це величезний плюс. П'ять років тому Російська Федерація мала в Україні все
починаючи від 80-ти відсотків мас-медіа, а також усю економіку, правоохоронну сферу, армію
політиків і політичні групи, які повністю все окупували
Зараз, на щастя, ми від цього вже відійшли.
Мустафо, дуже вам дякую.
Я нагадую, що ми говорили з Мустафою Найємом про п'ятиріччя Євромайдану
Залишайтеся з нами на Deutsche Welle